ladies and gentlemen welcome to the only
youtuber you can trust because i have a
lambo in the background knowledge come
on guys it's basic math
you can trust me because i have a lambo
and i'm crypto mining in the background
that's how you know
i'm trustworthy today i want to talk
about linus tech tips guys he recently
made a video
on crypto mining which i thought i
should address because uh
there's kind of two layers to this i
don't know if you call it like a
youtuber controversy but only one layer
has actually been
addressed and there's a way more
important piece which is being swept
under the rug right now
it's the part that linus tech tips
didn't tell you about in an eight minute
state uh
sponsored video or in the statement that
he released since then but before i get
into this video look i just want to say
in advance super important caveat i'm
quite familiar with linus tech tips work
i'm a fan like not a computer fan a real
fan
and as such i'd be remiss if i didn't
contextualize this video with the fact
that i think
you can still trust linux tech tips um i
think for the most part
they do really good deep work especially
for a channel who manages to also be so
prolific
so i'm saying this because i think that
even the best youtube channels can make
mistakes
and i think it's important to
distinguish between good actors who make
mistakes and bad actors who are
intentionally misleading you for profit
i don't think that's the case here
um so i want to be clear that they're
the former not the latter okay but that
said
we gotta go from the beginning okay
recently linus tech tips again
caught you up popular tech youtube
channel released a video called mind
crypto before it's too late
do you like money better yet do you like
free
money even if you're running an older pc
it could be worthwhile for you to start
mining while your system is idle now
this video
received immediate backlash and that's
because this video was sponsored
and entirely about nicehash a service
that can help you mine crypto with that
fancy new
gamer graphics card of yours okay but
the first layer of this fail is that
linus tech tips is actually notoriously
against large-scale crypto mining even
putting out a heavily critical video
called
nvidia doesn't care about gamers because
of their decision
with the crypto mining carts so this led
many people in this comment section to
see this video this new video as
hypocritical which is like
encouraging crypto mining and they were
everyone's saying oh you've become the
very thing you swore to destroy
and this is the part of it which he has
addressed he says in a statement
read today's video thank you for your
comments there's no denying
the environmental impact of mining and
the product shortages it contributes to
but this video does not advocate for
that kind of large-scale commercial
mining that does the majority of the
harm
this video is already out there we
aren't going to paper over it but with
that in mind i read you loud and clear
and we will think carefully about
partnerships in the mining space moving
forward
linus okay now to many people like the
story ends here
but it doesn't it gets much deeper and
ironically the statement
is actually papering over the more
concerning and serious issue here
which is that in an eight minute
commercial for nice hash
lioness never mentions the most
important piece of information for
anyone thinking of associating
themselves
with nicehash which is that their
founder is a convicted
cyber criminal who has served four years
and 10 months for cyber crimes
and in 2019 became wanted in the united
states
let me let that settle in that was never
mentioned
in a sponsored video for
nicehash that that's their founder see
nicehash's founder created
a malicious malware called the butterfly
botnet which was designed to steal data
online banking passwords and other
sensitive information and it also became
like one of the largest bot nets in
history
yes that's the founder of nicehash
that's who we're talking about here
we're gonna refer to him as
ms i'll put his name on screen i'm just
gonna butcher it if i try to pronounce
it
but to be clear that this is not a small
omission like oops i forgot to mention
that uh they got a speeding ticket back
in the day no no it's
massive and it rubs me in the wrong way
because in the video linus tech tips
mentions full disclosure and mentions a
hacking scandal nicehash has had in the
past
while failing to disclose the founder's
full history
now in the interest of full disclosure
nicehash was actually hacked a couple of
years ago
however unlike most other services and
exchanges
they actually used their own money to
eventually pay back
everyone who had any crypt to go missing
in full during the attack
which is actually the only reason that
we were comfortable working with them on
this project
because remember guys it's not your
mistakes that define you
it's how you handle the fallout after
it's like saying full disclosure hey
jeffrey epstein
he's been known to get a little flirty
but you never mentioned the actual full
history
you know past criminality doesn't mean
someone is a criminal today
the sketchy history with ms is from the
late 2000s
but it is absolutely relevant to know if
you're gonna put money and install
software
from a dude who has gone to jail for
creating software
that helps people steal money right like
if you're interviewing
the future head of security for like a
bank and they don't tell you
that they have a rap sheet for robbery
that's ridiculous that's absurd again it
doesn't mean you can't hire the person
but you the viewer or the hirer deserve
to know that right you deserve to know
that piece of information and linus tech
tips
did a sponsored piece and never gave
that out
and the statement doesn't even mention
it instead it's been turned into oh i
hear you about this environmental issue
which is important but misses the bigger
point and look i get it
this video might be shared around the
nice hash community so let me quickly
familiarize you
with some of their talking points about
the founder because this is not the
first time
this has come up he's addressed it and
they have their ways of kind of talking
their way around this
and i want to address them just so
you're fully informed according to one
of his interviews ms basically says he's
an innocent guy
caught up with some trouble he says i've
never been a hacker it's just
a big misunderstanding i'm just a
programmer
i've never buzzed it in anywhere or
stole anything at all
i was told that i wrote a software that
was used by others
for evil purposes what a sweetheart this
is a massive dodge though
the truth is that ms was the founder and
administrator
of dark ode which is described as quote
the most prolific english-speaking cyber
criminal forum
to date and on that forum which he
created he also created
the butterfly bot which he advertised on
that forum
according to the us indictment as being
undetectable
by many anti-virus packages he also
advertised the software had
the capability to steal sensitive
information including usernames and
passwords for banks
and other financial institutions from
users of firefox internet explorer web
browsers and included ddos features
so let's be clear ms
is claiming he innocently created a
program that was
repurposed for bad thing like he was
just a good guy
when in actuality he ran a cyber
criminal forum and sold the bot
on that forum which was designed to be
used
for evil purposes and was advertised as
such
so this dodge is nothing but clever pr
and this strategy by the way of
plausible deniability is also nothing
new
for ms a screenshot from the now defunct
website
shows you even back then how he
described his cyber criminal forum
let's bring it up check this out you
guys are gonna love this dude
look at this so it goes welcome to dark
code international marketplace for
sewing machines and other legal stuff
this is how they describe
what europol described as like the most
prolific cyber criminal forum
an international marketplace for sewing
machines and other
legal stuff so you should know that
context when now his new tagline is
i was never a hacker i was a programmer
right i didn't i didn't do anything it
was other
people yeah right and pablo escobar
sells phones now right
um in conclusion is nicehash
a trustworthy website has ms performed
his ways cleaned up his act in the last
few years has he learned his lesson in
jail
and do the past actions of a founder
dictate like
the the goals and do they taint the
future projects they have
i have no idea look i'm not saying you
should distrust nice hash whether you do
or not is a personal decision
what i am sure of though is that you
deserve to know
the history of the company's founder
before
putting your computer in the hands of a
guy who bragged that his
malware could evade detection from
antiviruses right
and to linus tech tips specifically i'm
pretty sure that things just slipped to
the cracks here
and due diligence was just missed on
this one i mean i think that's the only
way they can explain the lack of
disclosure here is that linus simply
wasn't aware
but what i can't get away from is that
this is a huge miss
and that even though i'm sure like
they're putting up infrastructure to
make sure a massive disaster
never happens like this again um i do
think it's worth saying that like
his statement is definitely missing the
point on this if linus wasn't aware of
nicehash's history before
he definitely is now and the fact that
he didn't make that part of his
statement
makes it seem like he was doing the
opposite of what he claims to be doing
in his statement which is
papering over a mistake right instead
he's saying like i'm not doing that
i'm like we'll just learn from it in the
future but it seems like you're papering
over a bigger mistake by admitting to a
smaller one
that being said i still like his tech
videos i'll continue to watch him
and i'll continue to take him as an
authoritative source on
non-sponsored videos in the end for you
the viewer
it's a great lesson that no one's
infallible not me not linus tech tips
no one and that you should do your own
research i hope this has helped explain
the whole situation with nicehash
and whatever you guys decide to do
minecrypto or not you have all the facts
uh i wish you the best and uh yeah
that's basically it
see you next time
wake up and smell the coffee